Voiceover:The price of
things at two supermarkets
are different in different cities.
Toilet paper in Duluth,
Minnesota cost 3.99 a package
while toilet paper in New
York City cost 8.95 a package.
In Duluth, toothpaste costs $1.95 a tube
while in New York City
it costs $5.25 a tube.
The data for this can be encoded
in the following grocery matrix.
Let's see if this makes sense.
They have the price of
toilet paper in Duluth 3.99
that's this right over here.
Then they have the price of toilet paper
in New York at 8.95
so that's this right over here.
This first row right over here,
this is the toilet paper row.
I'll just write TP for short,
that's the toilet paper row
and this first column
looks like it's Duluth
while this second column
looks like it's New York City.
Let's see if that works
out for the other data.
In Duluth a toothpaste cost $1.95 a tube,
so this data right over
here, is right over here.
This looks like the toothpaste row.
Toothpaste actually is also TP
so I'll just write out tooth.
This is the toothpaste row,
this is toothpaste in Duluth, $1.95.
Toothpaste in New York City, 5.25.
That's how they have set-up
the data right over here.
Which statements are true
about the above matrix?
Select all that apply.
The following matrix can also be used
to contain the same information as G.
That's what's interesting
about the matrix,
what we have right over here
is essentially an encapsulation
of all of the data
that we have in this upper paragraph
and it's useful because a computer
could make use of this data
as long as it knows what these rows
and what these columns actually represent.
The first thing they ask us
is whether the following
matrix can also be used
to contain the same information.
Let's see, this is the price
of toilet paper in Duluth
and this right over here is the price
of toilet paper in New York City.
They have the exact same first row,
I would say that looks
like the toilet paper row
and that would be Duluth column
and this would be the
New York City column.
Then if we define things that way
then this would have to
be the toothpaste row,
but the price of toothpaste in Duluth
is not 5.25,
and the price of
toothpaste in New York City
is not 1.95.
This one is not representing
the same information
as that up there.
You can't just randomly order this around.
Now you could represent it in other ways,
you could have another ...
Let's say I have the matrix A,
we could have picked to
do something like this
where we could have said
well maybe this is the toothpaste column
and maybe this is the toilet paper column,
and that this first row is New York City
and the second row is Duluth.
You could have done something like this
toothpaste in New York City was 5.25,
toilet paper in New York City is 8.95,
toothpaste in Duluth is 1.95
and toilet paper in Duluth is 3.99.
This would have been, this matrix A
that I've just constructed,
this does contain the same data
because if we appropriately
define our columns and rows
to represent toothpaste or toilet paper
in New York City or Duluth,
you can contain that information.
The problem with this one
is it's not consistent.
This first row makes us think,
okay this must be the Duluth column,
this must be the New York City column
and that the second row must be toothpaste
since the first row is toilet paper
but then they got things mixed up.
If they switch these two things around
then obviously you get the same matrix
but then at least the data
would have been consistent.
I definitely would not
say that this matrix
contains the same information.
The second column represents
the price of toothpaste
in the two cities.
The second column is this right over here,
no, that's not the price of
toothpaste in the two cities,
that's the price of
the two different goods
in New York City,
so I wouldn't check that one either.
Element G two comma one is equal to 5.25,
so when someone says ...
If you have the matrix
and they give you two comma one.
These are the indices of
the row and the column,
so this is a second row, first column.
Let's go there, second
row so this is one, two,
second row, first column
is right over there.
G two comma one is not 5.25,
so I wouldn't check that one either.
A change in the price of
toilet paper in Duluth
can be represented by the matrix.
Toilet paper in Duluth is this entry
of our matrix right over there.
Change in toilet paper in Duluth
would represent a change in this 3.99
but they didn't change the 3.99,
they changed the 9.75.
The 9.75 would represent a change
in the price of toilet
paper in New York City.
I wouldn't check that one either,
so I would only go with none of the above.